[Music]
this morning on the dish a spectacular
food and beverage pairing of a couple of
jared's acclaimed chef jared wentworth
and brewmaster jared rubin have created
quite a buzz with their chicago
restaurant by pairing fine dining with
in-house crafted beers in a two-star
review the michelin guide says their
culinary fireworks will lift your
spirits and have you returning for more
and after a visit i'd add and more and
more and more
on a quiet street in chicago's south
loops it's moody tongue a playground of
pairing it's 12 course tasting menu
meticulously prepared by chef jared
wentworth presentation
just gorgeous chef jared's a master with
beers like this pair saison brewed by
his partner jared rubin what you're
going to experience is the pear and the
acidity
complements the caviar and the matsutake
moshi which is a
japanese egg custard so think like
scrambled eggs and caviar
with
my normal wear scissors today
i'm gonna take a sip
that's why i love pairing food with beer
is the carbonation just like in
champagne those bubbles cleanse the
palate are you really gonna you're gonna
let me finish all right
i was trying to be polite there's no
reason to be here
patient is another story each bite and
sip to be savored with each course
oh my god
chef grew up in the northeast he loves
nantucket-based gallops they're so sweet
it's like candy almost prepared with
japanese artichokes and grits made with
a movie theater munchie that steals the
show scallops are like butter
the texture difference with the little
popcorn
popcorn grits oh he actually makes
popcorn and then reduces it down with
vegetable stock
it incorporates it in there and wash it
down with a little truffle a shaved
black truffle pilsner to be specific i'm
gonna guess it's the food decisions
before the beer decision sometimes
sometimes uh chef jared will come down
the brewery and he'll taste beers and
fermentation
isn't that cute again i mean this is
these are works of art
this is insane you first chef jared i
love you already
we'll meet chef in a bit but there are
still two more courses to revel in i'm
already thinking i couldn't pick a
favorite if you if you made me i
couldn't pick a favorite and that's
always the goal they have to all work
together and it's a progression so this
is our huckleberry half of eisen my
uncle iron sends me these huckleberries
from idaho every year
he pairs that with squab chanterelle
mushrooms sweet potato and chipolini
look at the huckleberries on top this is
fall on a plate yeah look at the colors
wow we call this pairing bridging they
build a bridge of complementary flavors
right and they come together oh my gosh
shall we
get that hungry
i'm coming to your side now
[Laughter]
and for dessert right now we're having a
bourbon barrel aged gingerbread imperial
stout
oh my it's like a gingerbread cookie was
dipped in a glass of heaven hell bourbon
i'm a louis william
bourbon is really important
and so is beer so we bring these two
worlds together
only topped by
s'mores rubin fell in love with brewing
at the culinary institute of america
where he first started pairing food with
his home brews now it's time to check
out the bird to see where he brews now
reuben took us to his secret beer
factory right below the restaurant
welcome to the moody tongue brewing a
place willy wonka might dream up if he
got tired of making chocolate so we're
gonna actually pull beer okay from this
barrel where the only danger is catching
a buzz this beer has been in the barrel
for about a year and a half a 12-layer
bourbon-barrel-aged imperial stout
before it's been carbonated
i mean still delicious ruben started
moody tong brewery in 2014. two years
later he had a tap room after a
collaboration with jared wentworth in
2019 the pair expanded opening the
moodytong restaurant and bar did anybody
think you were crazy that you were going
to go down this road i mean people think
i'm generally crazy regardless
but yeah i think people were a little
bit skeptical that you couldn't elevate
uh beer to the level of cuisine
um that you know is worthy of a couple
michelin stars so it really is one of
those um we have a good time we don't
take ourselves very seriously we just
like like to feed people the bar at
moody tongue features an a la carte menu
everything here we want to be
sophisticated like beat tartar and whole
black bass it's stuff we can't get away
with doing symbol-sized portions of yet
has the same exceptional taste which
earlier this year helped moody tong earn
two michelin stars i've been blessed and
part of that's through
a lot of hard work a lot of suffering
for your art essentially i've kept
michelin stars pretty much throughout my
whole tenure in chicago
i never take it for granted do we want
stars of course we do like we we work
our asses off to get that for me it's
the satisfaction of seeing a smile on a
diner's face
i think it's the biggest thing is that
instant gratification of making somebody
happy cheers cheers
whether it's the beer or the food it's a
feeling which at moody tongue you simply
can't escape this is our little slice of
cake there's no there's nothing little
about this slice of cake oh my god
also i want to uh warn you that this
beer is like 3 000 alcohol
i don't care how many calories this is
oh i don't think it's that many but
you're such a liar but i don't really
know
can i please live here
yes
oh
yeah i know i tried to get you the cake
i couldn't do it but we did bring beer
for you and this is what i loved in the
tasting and so this is the michelin
lager this is a juice lychee ipa and the
bourbon barrel aged barley wine i love
that they served the beer
in wine glasses and it just added to the
whole atmosphere of everything you
tasted and you wouldn't expect you're
waiting for wine with these courses and
it's absolutely delicious mmm it looks
cheers yeah
i'm sure it tastes like it i know i know
second course here
and i will say so obviously the
restaurant has two michelin stars jared
wentworth as a chef
has ten what yeah i mean highly highly
acclaimed chef and seems to be having so
much fun with his group there
pursuing his passion oh yeah god try
this one this is this
[Music]
it never crashes
never runs out of memory and it's always
up and running if that sounds like a
dream machine of the future think again
we'll see how a technology that hit its
peak decades ago is winning over new
fans
and next week on cbs saturday morning bj
novak may be best known for his role in
the office but the actor's resume
includes credits as a comedian producer
and writer we'll talk to him about the
new series he created and his feature
directing debut that is next week you're
watching cbs
saturday morning
[Music]
come alive for me
[Applause]
[Music]
so which stout is this this is not this
is the this is the bourbon barrel aged
barley wine it's not the one that i
tasted not the bourbon barrel aged
ginger no but i do have that gingerbread
one which is amazing this is the hard
part too so obviously you saw some of my
expressions during the tasting
they are so meticulous about it the
flavors just pulled out so when we had
the first dessert and you're having the
same chocolate taste that pulls out in
the in the beer
as is in the dessert you're eating again
i know we do this with wine all the time
i just had never thought about the idea
that you would do it with beer well and
he talked when he talked about the
notion of
the carbonation like in champagne
cleaning the pallets
so that you can taste the flavors even
more in just
revisiting the new tastes that's why i
love carbonated seltzer i mean it just
there's something about the fizz that
just kind of just
puts the end on whatever it is you're
having this is a little better than
seltzer yeah i was just gonna say yes
but it was also interesting i don't know
that i'd ever tasted beer that didn't
have the carbonation in it yet so when
we went into that barrel room and we
were tasting some of it it really was
like a almost like the when you're
making a cake and you take taste the mix
you know before you're done not that
anybody would do that it had that all
the time yeah it has that same kind of
taste and flavor and feel to it it's
really it's just an amazing space that
tasting room is so small and then you
have the bar space which is open for as
we mentioned this a la carte menu and uh
a wonderful stop it'll add to our list
of places awesome good stuff